are you going back to school this
September let me give you some advice
why are you in school is the question
you should always ask yourself because
in most cases you're going into debt so
you want to create some value yes the
education is important but it's also who
you're going to meet there some of the
people in your classes are going to be
your friends for the rest of your life
and your business associates they will
go out into every sector of the economy
and one day you'll be able to call them
up and say look I'm doing something here
or there and I would need your help I'd
like to collaborate with you or I need
some information you may have they will
know you from the old days that is your
network